Oh bigoted I'm born amid it without a
woman quota but many others feel they're
stopped and stuck halfway up the career
ladder let's talk a bit about that Hina
topic joins me now he's the founder of
generations CEO and that is a business
network for women good to have you with
us
as an expert first of all I'm interested
in your take on the women's quota will
it change anything is it necessary
unfortunately I have to give you a split
answer to answers in fact as a
businessman I can only say the quota is
there I will get additional business
it's fine with me however on the other
side I'm a great believer in democracy
free decision-making so legal quotas I
hate them they are strictly against my
own beliefs well you're not alone there
are a lot of women especially women in
powerful positions who share your
opinion but if a quota shouldn't or
can't change people's attitude
what else can well first of all a quota
cannot change attitudes that that is
really is my strong belief the you can
only change edit use by economic
arguments saying there are statistics in
the u.s. that prove the fact that the
more woman you have a top level in the
executive team the more profitable the
companies become and I mean that is the
strongest argument you can have because
it means tall males if we get more women
at the top we are more money very simple
and males you get very very easily with
the you know additional money little
additional bonus now these statistics
that you mentioned they're of course
known also to top executives to the big
decision makers yet we still have very
very few women in top management
positions on executive boards why is
that because they are well educated we
also know that from statistics there are
various reasons one is they study the
wrong subjects you know you find very
few women in engineering production
technical fields etc and that is a
handicap in Germany with with our big
technology and technology companies if
if you want to get to the top you have
to bring something from that corner and
not only HR and not only communications
so that is a big problem the other
problem is that women tend to leave the
company admit level because they they
get married they get children and they
drop out and unfortunately the companies
are yet not smart enough to keep them in
the loop and motivate them to come back
as soon as possible so when I listen to
you mean because a lot of these
arguments we've heard them over and over
again for so many years and I mean
biologically a woman is not a man so
that is a given what about the problem
just briefly of male bonding that is
also a cliche that we hear a lot or is
it maybe not a cliche but the truth
melts far better networking than than
females and they they've been doing that
for hundreds of years so and the rules
of their a male male mate rules if you
want to change that you've got to get up
there ok ok and networking is a very
good cue you give me here I saw a book
thank you very much for joining me